c'est votre ex indique ça c'est mon
accent quoi ça c'est fini entre vous
deux pagaille addiction qu'est ce qu'il
a fait il m'a encore tromper ni si en
plus ce nom après que soit venu avec
quelques nations après sa réunion s'est
passée ta compagne qui avec mais là à
marbella
roger milla le jour et quatre pays la mê
me lasser qui c'est ça qui s'est fait
refaire les fenêtres way we à l'eau et
voici comment alors alors est-ce que
c'est comme le menton des bogdanov et
donc tu l'a trompée avec me l'a juste un
bisou arrête quelques bisous avec la ou
je te oui il a quitté pour un bisou avec
nous ça allait pas se tromper mais
jamais dire jamais et l'acte et de
célibataires nom et lui les célibataires
6 en couple et lui les célibataires je
fréquente geoffrey alias que ce serait
ton style mais vous arrive à travailler
ensemble sans ménagement journalistes